alexandre vinik jugé en appel ce matin à
paris cet informaticien russe soupçonné
d'escroquerie aux bitcoin en première
instance le tribunal l'avait relaxé pour
les cyberattaques au beach games et
l'avait condamné à cinq ans de prison
pour blanchiment de fonds extorqués
les etats-unis demandent son extradition
il risque la base 55 ans de prison pour
les précisions dessel farges la cour
d'appel de paris confirme le jugement en
première instance à l'encontre
d'alexander vinik il est donc relaxé
pour des cyber attaques au bitcoin mais
condamné à cinq ans de prison pour
blanchiment de fonds extorqués alexander
vik est sous le choc de cette
condamnation c'est ce que nous a confié
son avocat qui précise que le russe va
se pourvoir en cassation
pour nous je vais vous dire que c'est
une déception parce que la cour d'appel
ne fait que confirmer simplement ce qu'a
dit le tribunal elle ne tient pas compte
de ce que les débats ont pu montrer elle
ne tient pas compte du fait qu'il s'agit
de preuve qu'ils n'ont pas été contrôlés
par des juges
il ne tient pas compte du fait que ces
preuves ont été sous le contrôle des
autorités étrangères et il ya donc une
déloyauté très clair pour pour nous dans
concernant le la preuve
alexander vinik et commis des actes de
blanchiment
c'est que la raison pour laquelle nous
allons nous pourvoir en cassation pour
rappel alexander vinik a été arrêté en
grèce en 2010 est à la demande de la
justice américaine est là bas il est
accusé de blanchiment de cybercrime
il a finalement été remis temporairement
en 2020 à la justice française est cette
dernière le réclamait après une enquête
portant sur une vague de rançons sur
internet via un logiciel est dénommée
loki noter que la russie la russie a
aussi demandé son extradition il a là
bas il est poursuivi pour une affaire
d'escroquerie